um you know I always wanted to know this
um
a song like paranoid comes out the label
puts Bob on it you're on the original
yeah at the time I'm sure you felt some
type of way but like I didn't talk to Ty
for months behind this [ __ ] yeah tell me
what happened there because I remember
like having the OG version of my Serato
and then obviously the version that the
label works because Bob was on fire as a
label mate you know again back to the
music business
I didn't [ __ ] with time for that and
Todd's my brother you know I didn't [ __ ]
with him I'm like [ __ ] I showed up to
the video shoot like thinking it was our
video shooting it was Bob there I'm like
I'm like what the [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
interesting [ __ ] ass [ __ ] well that's
how me and Ty talk to each other but
that's my brother though don't get it
[ __ ] up but I'm like you guys look
like you could also literally be
brothers yeah that's my that's really my
brother I was with him last night like I
don't give a [ __ ] what he do I'm gonna
[ __ ] what he got going on that's the
situation I had to get over too and then
I just got so much respect for LA radio
DJ e-man I got so much love for just
different people at Power and and Philly
they like played that version they like
man Joe most version better yeah we're
gonna play We sticking behind Joe Moses
you know what I'm saying like even when
people think I'm taking shots at TI I'm
like nah I'm not taking shots but that
was [ __ ] I shouldn't say something
like that about a man's wife you know
what I'm saying and I I'm older to admit
that now I mean listen I was just
rapping though you were just rapping and
sometimes when you're just rapping you
just be saying some [ __ ] I was just
talking everybody listen to my music
they they hear I say all type of [ __ ] so
I was just rapping it wasn't no shot at
T.I like I was just rapping and it's
like not like you knew TI at the time
yeah I was just rapping bro it wasn't it
wasn't it wasn't personal you know what
I'm saying everybody thought it was
personal everybody like oh you taking
shots
urban legend is one of my favorite
albums in the world like what you
talking about like it could be his best
it's best that one of trap music come on
both it's one of those things you know
what I'm saying like trap music hey
let's get away let's get a room on the
other side of town urban legend like you
gotta stop yeah ASAP these kids together
man that one kid is [ __ ] turned up
you don't gotta do nothing man that's
how he spoke no I like how he spoke on
it though you know what he said he said
I gave him all the game I could give him
it's up to him now he's gonna have to go
to jail or something and my daddy told
me the same exact thing you know I went
to prison
just because you grew up a certain way
you can't coddle like a kid I like how
T.I responded to all the backlash
because he was like yo like yo I I told
him everything I could tell him it's on
him now so you got all these
[ __ ] on the internet that's
that's that's that's that's
focus on what we doing in life really
Instagram you should be charging these
[ __ ]
[ __ ] a monthly fee to be able to say
all this negative [ __ ] to us right you
know what I'm saying we should charge on
Instagram if you want to see my life
[ __ ] I should be able to charge
you to see my life they have that it's
called only fans yeah but I'm talking
about my real I'm talking about on this
Instagram [ __ ] right that life
technically you can do that on IG now
yeah you can uh you people can subscribe
to your page uh for like exclusive
content that only goes to your
subscribers on IG so technically not my
points
do you what that's only fans
only fans you can run it up